I am asking you for your help we have
launched a major indiegogo crowdfunding
campaign we learned that corporate media
failed progressives in the 2016 election
and it's time to build something better
we need to create real progressive
engagement and that is exactly one of
the things that we're seeking to do with
this campaign we need to enable
progressives to take action and we also
need to continue making some major
improvements to the production of the
david pakman show i've never lost sight
of the reality that you the TDPS
audience have been the primary and most
important driving force of the growth of
the david pakman show and we've had an
impact we've already surpassed and
outlasted 99% of the independent
programs that started back in two
thousand five years before President
Obama's first term our first year in
existence and my goal has always been
stand up to corporate media stand up to
the status quo of the political world
and the time has come to start the next
chapter of not only the david pakman
show but of independent progressive
political activism and i don't have to
tell you the progressive movement lost
big league on november eighth 2016 but
if there is a silver lining it's that
it's now clearer than ever that the
status quo of corporate media and
republicans out organizing progressives
at the local and state level it just
cannot continue it has to stop and by
the way nearly half the country didn't
vote in the 2016 election i certainly
remember and i assume you do that
sinking feeling as we realized that
Donald Trump would be the next president
of the United States and that should
motivate us to put together an effective
progressive playbook corporate media
could not have failed us more acutely
they ignored Bernie Sanders until they
had no choice they reported timidly
about the outrageous ideas of Donald
Trump and we cannot just be wandering
aimlessly for strategy and candidates to
move the country forward and we
absolutely cannot
the hate that has risen in the wake of
Donald Trump's election we have to have
strong and well-funded independent
progressive media even if Hillary
Clinton had one we would still have
Republicans controlling the House and
Senate we would probably be ignoring the
urgency of fixing congressional
gerrymandering with the 2020 census and
Bernie Sanders is candidacy while not
perfect did show us that progressive
engagement has a major impact the halt
of the Dakota access pipeline after
relentless progressive protesting and
organizing confirmed again that activism
can have a major impact and as we get
past the despair and the confusion of
november eighth we must have a plan the
david pakman show has one and i want you
to be a part of it I actually need you
to be a part of it we've built a
successful independent media platform at
the david pakman show but the show alone
is simply not enough so we are launching
a major campaign to not only
fundamentally grow our reach but also to
grow the influence of progressive media
in some extraordinary new ways we're
gonna be growing not only the media
presence of the show but also the
activism and the progressive engagement
arm this campaign will allow us to
number one hire a progressive engagement
coordinator to organize and coordinate
progressive action on issues and
candidates that matter we are going to
organize and partner with existing
independent progressive shows to
coordinate activism and exponentially
increase the impact of our efforts we're
going to upgrade the david pakman show
studios to the next level of
professionalism including a real
professional set design as well as
professionalizing the guest interview
technology platform and we're also going
to bring the david pakman show to amazon
prime this is just a huge opportunity to
reach a much larger audience it has
significant tech and staff requirements
and its extensive enough that it exceeds
current staff capacity and we're going
to create a true david pakman show
mobile broadcast capability right now i
can basically skype into the Boston
studio from remote locations which is
very limiting in a lot
ways and to truly do remote broadcasts
from areas where activism is happening
we need the ability to edit and
distribute the program remotely and that
will greatly increase our ability to be
activists and additionally we are going
to start developing long-form interview
content with brilliant progressive minds
in-person interviews with people who
truly can equip us to be change agents
and also to teach us how to most
effectively lobby for progressive change
I need your support please look at the
perks that we are offering look at the
fundraising goal and make the largest
contribution you can you also can refer
donors to the campaign we've got a
referral contest which you can read
about towards the bottom of the campaign
page and you can use the Facebook and
Twitter buttons on the campaign page to
refer donors to the campaign that is
also absolutely huge if there's a perk
you want that would get you to make a
big donation please don't hesitate to
reach out to me through the website
david pakman.com if there's anything we
can do to engage you or people in your
network to become donors please don't
hesitate to ask because there's just too
much riding on this this is the biggest
initiative we've ever done and I'm
asking for your help to make it happen